cuando queremos asignarle un nombre a
una a una molécula compuesta por muchos
carbonos en realidad
la parte central es fijarnos cuántos
carbonos tiene esta cadena o esta
molécula verdad entonces por ejemplo si
nosotros queremos asignarle un nombre a
esta molécula digamos ahí tenemos esto
aquí así entonces a lo mejor tú podrás
decir bueno cómo es que esto podría
representar una cadena verdad perdón una
o una molécula en realidad estamos
pensando y este es un repaso del vídeo
anterior que en cada uno de estos
vértices o en cada uno de estos extremos
tenemos carbonos verdad déjenme pintar
primero carbono cada uno de estos
extremos de estas líneas son carbonos y
i e implícitamente estamos diciendo que
el resto de los enlaces están ocupados
por hidrógeno por ejemplo este primero
como ya tiene un enlace a otro carbono
le tocan otros tres enlaces que conectan
con hidrógeno es verdad entonces podemos
observar que esta cadena tiene
es 456 carbonos y que no tenemos enlaces
múltiples así que antes de continuar con
la asignación del nombre de esta
molécula voy a voy a enumerar o voy a
enlistar todos los prefijos con los que
vamos a estar trabajando en en en
química orgánica ok entonces por ejemplo
cuando tenemos un carbono tendremos el
prefijo met ok cuando tenemos dos
carbonos será el prefijo es muy bien
cuando tenemos tres carbonos tendremos
el prefijo prop muy bien cuando tenemos
cuatro tendremos el prefijo wood y
esencialmente estos cuatro son los dos
únicos digamos que son especiales para
la asignación de nombres de
hidrocarburos porque a partir del quinto
usamos los ya ya los clásicos digamos
los ya conocidos en el quinto sería pent
verdad en el sexto sería ex verdad esto
es por ejemplo pueden pensar los como si
fueran polígonos tenemos un pentágono o
un hexágono verdad en el séptimo sería
18 sería como octágono verdad 9 este es
el raro verdad es non por ejemplo no no
no
ok y el de y cuando tenemos 10 pues
vamos a tener deck muy bien ahora cuando
tenemos más de 10 puedes cambiar un
poquito verdad tenemos el once sería un
deck un indec así por ejemplo si
queremos decir una cadena de 11 carbono
sería el decano verdad cuando tenemos 12
sería el 2 como cuando tenemos un
polígono de 12 lados sería donde cada
uno verdad si tenemos 13 pues ya podrás
adivinar verdad el primero era un deck
sería como uno más 10 el 12 sería 2 + 10
el 13 pues sería 3 más 10 que sería
three de verdad
cuando tenemos 14 pues tendría tetra de
que detrás de él y el 15 sería 30 de
verdad y así podría seguir t por ejemplo
el 16 sería ex a tec el 17 sería esta
deck 18 sería oct a dec el 19 serían una
decks y el 20 es el único que cambia que
sería el tendría una un prefijo cos
verdad pero bueno vamos a quedarnos con
esto yo creo que con esto va a estar
para tener muy clara la idea de cómo es
la asignación del prefijo entonces si
nosotros quisiéramos
ver la nomenclatura de este de esta
cadena de carbonos entonces simplemente
nos fijamos que tiene 6 tiene 6 carbonos
entonces nos fijamos en el prefijo ex y
yo al inicio les comenté que éste no
tenía enlaces dobles o triples entonces
a las cadenas de carbono de esta forma o
estos hidrocarburos que no tienen
enlaces múltiples entre los carbonos se
les conoce como alcanos ok esto es un
alcano entonces como se va a llamar este
este hidrocarburo pues en realidad se va
a llamar hexano hexano primero ex del
prefijo y vamos a ponerle la terminación
a no justamente porque es un arcano
entonces este es el hexano muy bien
vamos a ver otro ejemplo digamos que
tengo este
ahí lo tienen entonces esta es
nuevamente una cadena de carbono como ya
hemos visto en otros vídeos ahora
contamos cuántos carbonos tenemos 1 2 3
4 5 6 y 7 porque cada extremo representa
un carbono entonces tenemos 7 carbonos y
por lo tanto a éste le corresponde el
prefijo es verdad y es un arcano
entonces hoy le llama eta no verdad
ahora bien vamos a ver un último ejemplo
qué pasaría si yo tengo algo así esta
molécula de aquí entonces nuevamente
contamos cuántos carbonos tenemos en
esta cadena y tenemos 1 2 3 4 y 5 5
carbonos verdad entonces a éste le
corresponde el nombre de venta no porque
no tenemos enlaces múltiples ahora bien
qué pasaría si por ejemplo esta
estructura no estuviera así digamos en
en una línea sino más bien en una línea
quebrada si no estuviera en un ciclo es
decir en vez de estar
de esa forma que estuviera de esta otra
forma
ok entonces nuevamente solo para no
perder la idea cada uno de los extremos
de estas líneas representa un carbono
entonces aquí tendremos un carbono un
carbono un carbono un carbono y un
carbono que están unidos por enlaces
simples verdad entonces uno podría
pensar que es un arcano y sólo para
recordar pues cada uno de estos está
necesita cuatro enlaces y cada uno de
estos está unido a otros dos así que
cada uno de estos deberá estar unido
esto más bien en esta estructura estaba
implícito que está unido a otros dos
hidrógenos pero cómo puedes darte cuenta
esto ya se empieza a volver muy
engorroso y muy amontonado y por eso es
que no nos gusta estar poniendo tantas
tantas cosas verdad es más fácil poner
simplemente el anillo de en medio y
dejar implícito que cada extremo es un
carbono y está unido a los hidrógenos
que le corresponden entonces este
también es un arcano pero está en una
estructura cíclica entonces a este de
aquí le vamos a conocer como
venta no muy bien entonces si queremos
por ejemplo desmenuzar el nombre ciclo
significa que en realidad es un anillo
verdad el pent el pent este pen
significa que tiene 5 carbonos verdad y
el y la terminación a no ponerlo con
amarillo la terminación a no significa
que los enlaces entre carbono son
simples verdad ahora vamos a hacer
otros ejemplos pero al revés primero
vamos a dar el nombre y vamos a ver si
podemos dibujar la estructura muy bien
entonces vamos a poner primero un nombre
imagínense que yo les digo que dibujen
el ciclo no nano
ciclo no nano que entonces tómate un
tiempo para pensar cómo dibujarlo
ok entonces si ya lo pensaste el nombre
es el o más bien que tenga el prefijo
ciclo significa que es un anillo
entonces la estructura que vayamos a
dibujar tiene que ser en forma de anillo
verdad el non el non significa que
tienen 9 carbonos muy bien y el ano
nos nos dice que tiene enlaces simples
las las conexiones entre carbono son
enlaces simples entonces vamos a ver si
puedo dibujar lo tenemos aquí
pero
9 y simplemente terminamos con este
enlace o que quizás fue un poco raro y
debería poner el punto de inicio este
quizás fue un dibujo muy mal hecho pero
se entiende la idea verdad tenemos un
ciclo con 9 carbonos en cada uno de
estos extremos hay un carbono y bueno
por supuesto el resto implícitamente son
hidrógenos verdad entonces ahí tenemos
el ciclo no nano vamos a ver otro
ejemplo y este ejemplo a lo mejor te
resulta familiar porque lo has oído en
las gasolineras verdad el octano esto es
un término o es la sustancia que está
presente en las gasolinas y que está
especificado por ejemplo cuando uno va a
la gasolinera entonces vamos a tratar de
ver cómo se dibuja la estructura de esta
molécula entonces tenemos primero que es
oct eso significa que tenemos 8 carbonos
y la terminación a no significa que es
un arcano y no tenemos el prefijo ciclo
así que simplemente va a ser como una
especie de estructura lineal
no verdad entonces tendremos 12345678
verdad y esta es la estructura del
octano ahora bien en los próximos vídeos
vamos a agregarle más a estas moléculas
y haremos nombres mucho más complicados